last off hello
and welcome now i i i plan to uh spend
today and probably monday
at part of monday anyway talking about
um another aspect of writing that's it
that
is suggested to me by barry here uh in
the audience there's a good idea about
talk about the refereeing process now a
lot of you will be asked to write
referee reports and and uh also you'll
be receiving referee reports and so on
and so this is an important part of
publication
and let's see first all to finish
some
some old business
oh yeah homework remember today was the
day that homework is due
and so be sure to turn in your homework
to the tas
and they will they will
grade it and give you a and we'll be
talking about the sequel to the homework
assignment next week as as we find out
what you what you did
look at
and see if there's any specific
things to point out good and bad about
what about the solutions to the problem
okay now
uh
okay now i mentioned the other day
the the paper that i did recently
uh for the math monthly and i since we
were talking about monthly lately and
this was the this is the
one where i had some correspondence with
with editor and i ran across this as i
was as i was working on my on my thing
for the uh
for for uh
on refereeing and so i think i think i i
think helmus was um
uh is is a a a great editor and um
and uh so uh
uh
here's the one here's the paragraph in
here it says uh
um
let's see one possible change the
referee refers to and i would like to
second is in the title of the paper and
of its sections jokes are dangerous in
the magazine like the monthly and the
profit from the ingenious double
meanings may turn out to be majorized by
the laws now you know you realize that
when you're writing to mathematicians
you would use language like this and it
would be more
it would he would he would write a
different letter to somebody else but uh
um
but uh i i mentioned that uh as i when i
when i wrote the original paper i got i
got carried away and uh and and i i had
to show you how carl carried i had to
show somebody how carried away i was
like like here was so here's the letter
um
uh
i understand that some people keep their
copies of the monthly in the bathroom
this paper's written especially for them
i had so the second section was called
an absorbing barrier and the third
section was called residues and i
thought
section was a process of elimination
the outcome
and uh cleaning up so so now the
no why
and then
my then the third reference that was was
flushed with pride
which is a wonderful uh which is a
wonderful book i would recommend to
anybody so it's the history of thomas
crapper inventor of the flush toilet and
uh
um there's a lot of interesting
background there i want to get into it
but anyway you see i got
i carried away on the other so he so
then he sent me this fatherly advice and
and i wrote back um
okay and i got a referee reporting here
too i guess and um
uh and so the the actual paper when it
comes out the sec the titles are called
recurrence relations the limiting
behavior you know our
special power series there's nothing uh
i i believe anymore left of the of this
the type but the title is there
now
now uh and that's um
and so i wrote them about the title
because um
because uh
uh let's see
what is the answer what is mine
um
oh goodness here his letter comes back
your toilet paper is accepted
oh well
um
okay where is it uh i'm sorry i must
have the letter that i wrote to him
about it but
but uh
basically
i hate to use the word basically
uh i said that um
i thought about the title and it seemed
to me
all right
because i had given two talks under this
title we used it in the
we used it in the um
ah here we go this is my letter
oh okay
i said i submitted the paper on november
4th and i got it i got back his his
letter in the referee report on november
30th that was incredible and then i said
i made the change except for one thing
the title is still the same i've already
given two lectures on the toilet paper
problem one was at ibm
a story about has gone into our campus
newspaper
problem was using a qualifying exam in
our department i discussed it with
numerous friends in all walks of life i
mean at my church i talked about it to
people in conversation stuff and i met
people who told me they've often
wondered about this problem which is
about the sizes of when you have two
rolls
of toilet paper to choose from what what
what can you predict about him things
like this and so anyway i'm confident
that there won't be an unfortunate
backlash except perhaps if senator
proxmyer gets wind of the nsf's support
um the subject isn't really raunchy like
hirari's pornograph which he uh
now um
um
and then and and so uh i so i said now i
have dispensed with with my uh
my double meanings
and uh and and actually helmet and i had
a conversation now where where he was
where he had been surprised that my
expletives were different from nixon's
and uh
and now our roles are reversed and you
are wisely telling me to clean up my act
and so uh
so yeah but but now since then i have
felt a lot of twinches of that i should
have changed the title of the paper
because every time i see
uh i see this sitting in my pile of
reprints or something it looks very
strange and so i'm not sure i made the
right decision on the title actually but
um
it it got attention to the to and it was
reviewed in you know i had reasonable
reviews in the uh
i haven't looked it up in the russian
reviewing journal that'll be fun to do i
think to see that but um uh
but the the mathematics was actually um
worthwhile and i didn't think that it
would that i would have this negative uh
reaction afterwards seeing it but just
you know just somehow it's it's very
much out of context and that um
and that does uh
uh
is disturbing no matter how logical or
illogical something is that things can
be disturbed you know the fact that that
they are that they are that different
is a factor that
i probably should have taken
taken account of
now let's see referee
there's
there's some literature about refereeing
but and i suppose it's gone on and on in
the it like this comes from science
magazine 1965 and it was sent to me when
i first became about the first year that
i was i was in the editorial game
and
and and this is
something that i think acm passed out to
its editors as uh as something that they
might want to take to heart
and
um
and uh well i didn't but i i don't care
for the i i don't think this was a great
uh a great paper but had some points in
it that i should mention that because
this this addressed the traditional view
of refereeing and i i think there's more
to it than what he has he he but he
thinks of refereeing as
as as more of a more of a game where
where there's there's legal rights and
responsibilities uh um
that
and he's not really
thinking of it as part of a
world enterprise of
advancing science so much as uh
as advancing people's careers and things
like that that's so that's that's not
the primary
reason for publication the primary
reason for publication is because you
want to publish something that you think
is that people are that that you're that
you wanted people to know that you think
is is it was worth the their their time
and and knowing and because it's another
little
a little um
stone in the edifice of science and that
you that uh what when you know all this
nice things but really this is one thing
that probably distinguishes uh people
from animals but the most is that we can
remember and we can build on on the past
because we have written communication
and we can each little each little uh
uh piece of work is uh
is uh uh
uh is
small in itself but uh
put a lot of these together and and this
is really what what makes a difference
over the years and uh you feel you have
that that's a good that's that's so cool
i think the right the reason to publish
but uh now anyway there's something that
i i have to remember then that the the
first duty of the referee is to is to
the editor uh the editor is sending out
a paper to a referee to
for for judgment and the referee is an
expert in this in this area
um and so as serving as an expert
witness that would be in a you know in a
legal case and uh
uh saying yes in my opinion i think this
is worth or or not worth publishing and
there's that aspect of it
but i i don't to me that was that's not
the uh that's not the the main thing and
i'll i'll talk more about that later uh
but here's another point that that
definitely uh that the referee
whenever the referee decides about that
that something is
is well known um you there's a duty to
to not to just say this is a known
result but you also want to cite chapter
and verse
why
why this thing is
is uh
you know already in the literature so
there doesn't it doesn't seem to be a
reason for it
to be not you know now um
uh so
and of course the the uh the editor is
asking the referee to
to to do this so that the editor can now
uh
uh make an informed judgment and the
editor has to write back to the author
saying yes your paper is should or
should not be published
um
and the uh um
the the main the main problem in all of
this is that the
the people who are are
publishing
for the wrong reasons are the ones that
are
going to take most of the editors time
in the referee's time because they will
be writing
something that doesn't really deserve to
be published but they won't believe that
it doesn't deserve to be published and
you have to prove it to them
you take a long time
spending a lot of a lot of hours for
somebody who
where you would rather put that many
hours into somebody who was going to
write
write better papers and really make more
contribution literature but what happens
is that instead you
you spend many hours agonizing over how
you're going to prove to somebody that
that this is trash and uh
um not to not to bother us again
but do it in a nice way
herb mentioned
fairmont's last theorem
being i i read a proof of fairmont's
last theorem in april uh
but the guy sent me also a proof of
riemann hypothesis which i declined to
to uh to read
um
and uh and so anyway they and then uh
when then then the author writes back to
the editor saying well the referee said
such and such but i counter propose by
you know my i have a counter argument
that really this uh the referee doesn't
know he's talking about and so on and so
on and this can take
an unfortunate amount of amount of time
for uh but uh
uh it doesn't
unfortunately this doesn't happen often
enough to really bog down the whole the
whole uh enterprise of science which you
could very well do
but uh my but i think the the main
the main thing uh referees should try to
do is is is consider a responsibility to
the author
as and not that not the primary response
and and the readers of the publication
but not but not only to the editor
and um
and if you have if you have a certain
number of hours to spend on
on
contributing to your profession
um
there's uh there's a trade-off and you
know how you're gonna uh
with how many hours are you gonna put
into the various aspects of of of of
things and one of the
and um one of the decisions that i
reluctantly made but i think it was it
was necessary in the
in computer science was that i decided
that i would put much more time into
into uh refereeing and editing papers
before they were published then
reviewing papers after they were
published
i i i mean there's review journals that
need that that need people to uh to
write reviews
um but i've but i decided that i would
put my time into the into getting the
things
better before they before they they had
to be reviewed instead of instead of
afterwards and and because computer
science was such a new field the
uh
standards had not
at that time uh
developed the point yet where so so uh
given the very few people who could be
good referees very few people could be
good good reviewers um
seemed to me we would put more more of
the people into refereeing and we didn't
have very many good reviewers left uh
after after publication um
uh now it's more mature field than we
can and we and i think uh it's better to
it you know you know a more balanced
situation is uh
is is is happening but this but uh put
an awful lot of time into
into refereeing because of the uh result
the idea was to to make the literature
as good as possible uh when it finally
gets in print uh this should not be
this should not be just a half
half-baked half-baked thing okay so so i
made up a list
in the 60s that uh
a little handout
called hints to referees
and um
and this um
i searched high and low for many hours
yesterday trying to find that because i
i must have sent out thousands of these
over the years and we used to send out
many every week because i had so many
papers going in and out
um and every time i would send this to
the referee and people and it was a
fairly good presentation of the
philosophy that i've
felt strongly about refereeing
um
they've all vanished and but i all i
found was a trace of it in this um
in a letter from 1970 saying uh
um
there's an information sheet with hints
for referees which we think every editor
should take to heart
uh and which we consequently enclose a
copy but i'm we didn't save the copy
because we already had all this it's one
of these things i had so many out so
i've i've sent so i so i know all the
people who got this letter and i sent to
them and asked them for if any of them
saved the enclosure that came with the
letter and maybe one of them is a pack
rat and has and has this uh but um
uh
i so maybe by the end of the quarter i
can show you what this what this is
because i thought i said it well but
maybe i'll try to remember what i what
what what i said in the in this hints to
referees
so many years later um
the
as i said the uh uh
one of the responsibilities is to the
readers of a publication we would like
to if possible that that when when a
paper comes out in a journal it would be
worth reading
before and and not
not just publish everything that comes
along and then and then let
some kind of law of evolution decide
and selection take place after that
point
ideally we'd like to have
things that people would
uh you know all
all the papers would be worthwhile in
the journal now why not
uh so i disagree a bit with one of the
things herb said uh
on wednesday that uh he would he would
uh
uh tolerate more uh
lapses in in a paper for the journal of
algorithms than than in a paper for the
monthly i i don't see why you have to
tolerate that uh particularly you can
still ask the author to do better
um and so one of the points i made for
my insta referees was that i is that
almost never is should a paper be
accepted as as it was submitted there's
always the author can always be you can
always do
do better
and there's a and and and uh
only once in my whole uh
in my memories it was it was was there a
paper submitted to me that i was not
able to think of a single single way to
improve it and i le and i published it
exactly as it was it was a paper by
by george collins in the uh
acm journal
and uh he had just optimized that as he
wrote it i mean his style wasn't wasn't
mine but it was for his style it was
just perfect and and there was nothing
to do but but almost always i suggested
that there was some way in which you
could ask for a minor revision that
before publication where the author
would do it
and
i also believe the author is appreciates
this i know it's a little more work
i've been an author myself and i've
known that
i get that i i i'm very glad
to know that somebody has read
something that i put time into carefully
and and has actually uh uh has suggested
how it can be made even better i think
this is wonderful
so
uh one of the so one of the
responsibilities is to the is to the
publication let's get the publication so
that people so that we can be proud of
our whole field the publications look
good this was definitely definitely not
true in the early 60s uh it's all kind
of flaky stuff getting getting in print
and
you had
you had uh let's see is it four
possibilities or three you can you can
get the right results with the wrong
proof you can get the
wrong results with the right proof no
that's the other one you can get the
wrong results with the wrong proof and
you can get the right result to the
right proof about
30
in each category
ten percent you can't figure out what
whether there's results no results at
all or something
and and uh
uh so it was it's really necessary to
put a lot of time into into into making
standard now if you look at if if you
look at a random math journal from
1930s uh 1920s or something like that i
think it's surprising how that that that
you that you'll recognize the authors of
almost every paper
and you'll and you'll also recognize the
results of many of those papers that
that is they've come down into textbooks
that that uh um
almost you know more than half of the
papers in uh you know in a in in a
journal will be will be uh something um
uh really polished and well known and
and and significant now
would that be true of a random journal
of the 70s no no way
um
uh
it's uh so i think uh the tower we got
people
got to be less
more tolerant of of poor quality um
now
the other thing is um
that i stressed in my hands to referees
was
to uh um
to
um
be
in the role of teacher for um
uh that is
uh he uh
off the the person who the the author of
this paper that you're referring is is
going to write other papers and it's
and is uh and is
is uh
learning uh as everyone goes through
life and learns more and uh you can and
and a referee is typically anonymous and
and uh and the author never finds out
who it is uh that this is so that the
referee is um
able to make critical comments without
making enemies essentially
um
and so uh
uh but but what but when you're when
you're uh
when you have this cloak of anonymity a
lot of people will will write something
that that's really uh uh tasteless uh
and will tear down the author in such a
way that that that how that is
completely
uh uh you know the author uh will will
get this and just be up just be just be
angry and and absolutely learn nothing
from the from the experience and uh so
so uh there's a there's a way to be to
give constructive criticism and this is
and and how to point out um
ways to make improvements in something
that so that it's so that it's clear to
the author that he can do better it's
clear but also how he can do better in
the next time he writes a paper and so
on and when the and and and so there's a
way there's a way of of of doing this
enough
you know in a way that you would do to a
student saying keep you know keep trying
here's a way to improve so but the uh
the this this aspect of it uh um
these more human weren't brought out in
this
article was disappointed not just not to
see that um now um referee also will
contribute um
uh
to the technical quality sometimes uh by
you know i mean certainly you you you
want to contribute references uh to to
work of which the author was unaware and
what and you want to check and say that
your proof of theorem two is false and
so on it's nice if you can actually
supply a correct proof of theorem too uh
that's not necessary uh but
but um
uh
there's there
uh but there are quite a few
times that uh um that i got sufficiently
interested in a problem that i decided
that i would
i would uh contribute a result to the
paper as as a referee and i and and
include that in the in in the referee's
comments
and um
so i must say there there are
at several dozen
people who don't know who i was that uh
but that'll have you know there's a note
in their paper saying thanks to the
referee for uh
you know theorems one two and three
essentially you know not quite but um
but uh you know it's for improving the
comments and and um
and that made me feel good that i was uh
in i mean somehow that i that that this
journal was
was getting better it was getting better
papers and uh and only i knew that that
uh that you know you know somebody
appreciated this and it was improving
the quality of the of the publication
and somehow
making the image of the journal as a as
a more infallible uh
thing to do that was um somehow i i i i
was pleased to have that kind of a role
um and i've seen that in many of the
other referees then as it was later as
an editor um and in my own papers as
i'll show you there's many cases where i
owe a lot to referees
um so so um uh so i kind of like this
idea of thinking of a of a journal as a
source of wisdom by
by
anonymous referees
and uh and
this kind of cooperation aspect of it
rather than a legalism rather than a
legal approach of what what our rights
of the different plaintiffs and
participants in in this thing that's a
completely
uh
uh distorted view of the of the
scientific publication process that i
that in my opinion
um uh now
let's see what's that was gonna say what
when you submit a paper what journal do
you submit to a lot of people ask you
know students will have have results and
they say look and uh the answer
typically is the one that has the best
referees for the subject of your paper
if unless you just want to get it
published then you if you just wanted to
get it published you would send to a
journal
that would would likely have a very
light
like you know a referee who wouldn't who
wouldn't know if
if this is already a known result you
know so um you can look at the editorial
board or you know if you if you're if
it's a sequel to some other paper that's
already been published in a particular
journal then you know
um
that this is a that this journal has has
people who have refereed this kind of
stuff before and what you want to know i
think if you're a conscientious author
is you want to know if you have really
made a contribution
and so you want to send to the place
that will tell you
quite frankly if it isn't and and be
able to judge you judge your work you
want to get that kind of confirmation
you don't want to leave that as an
unknown
so that's the choice uh try to find a
journal that has that has the
best chance of having a good giving a
good service a referee
um
yeah tracy
some journals have letters in them that
look very much like very small papers
are they refereed the same way that they
um sometimes they are yeah they're just
that's just their way of separating long
long papers from short papers
uh now there's there are some peop there
are some journals that have no
refereeing
and you know and there's conference
proceedings that have various different
levels of refereeing and so and and
things like this and uh
the um
the
readers generally expect uh
that they have to wade through a lot of
trash when they look at that at that
stuff and somebody i mean al perlis
you know there were proposals for acm to
publish an unreferee journal it's been
coming up ever since the middle 60s
maybe even earlier and he
burles compared this to attaching a hose
to somebody's mouth and letting anything
gush out that
they wanted it was just gonna you know
uh much better to have uh
to have a filter system
no filler system is perfect uh
and you know people get elected
president of the united states and so on
it's a hard job
campaigning goes on for years but
but is this really the filter system
that does it really do but it's it's
still better to apply
apply uh fly controls before publication
and after much better
now
now i have the speaking of president of
the united states um
when people run for president
they uh uh their past life is brought
under very careful scrutiny and uh and i
decided to fess up to something now that
i did in the 60s that i've never
told anybody before and i'm not sure i
should tell now but uh i've started it
and um
and uh but in case i ever run for
president it's going to come out anyway
and so somebody would discover this and
so i would have to so now i have to do
it so and that is i i began um uh editor
um
and uh
in 1965 um i was editing uh
programming languages for both the
communication asdm and the journal of
the acm and i began this in in
just at the end of at the end of 64
beginning of 65 and i decided that um
uh
i i didn't really know who
how to trust you know i heard a whole
bunch of possible referees but i didn't
have any idea if they'd be very good
referees or not
and so i decided to send the same paper
to about 12 people to to get referee
reports on
meanwhile i had already refereed the
paper myself very carefully so that i
knew what what the paper was and uh
and i
had already communicated with the author
that the paper needed major revision and
uh and so on but then i sent out so
here's a so here's a letter i sent to
the author on january 5th
and i said
essentially
what is it your paper has been referred
to me since i've just accepted
position program label as editor
we cannot publish this paper before
major revisions are made since the
important sections are so unclear then
close review gives one man's impressions
and suggests and so on
uh if i had not assigned the paper to
him he would probably not take as much
time as he did trying to understand it
so you see hardly any of our readers
would get much out of the paper in his
present form i had written this letter
then on january 11th i sent a letter to
uh
to seven people and i sent this same
paper out to quite a few other people
later on
and
um uh
and i always you know noted the date in
which i sent them the paper and i went
and how long it took to get the report
their their report back to me but this
was uh this uh
um
and and if i guess uh you know i didn't
lie i mean i said uh i hope you can
serve as referee for this paper i didn't
you know i was i just didn't go on and
tell them that uh that there
that they would uh that their report was
going to be just for my own calibration
purposes
but um anyway that's what i did and um i
didn't feel too guilty about it because
the paper actually even though
very badly written wasn't was was was
interesting as a as a as an algorithm
and uh and so although they'd be putting
some time on it they probably wanted to
know about this algorithm anyway or at
least like you know it wasn't wasn't a
total loss
for on their part to be to be spending
this time on on the
on the thing it was um a bit interesting
okay
uh well
so
now
uh
so i don't know
what which rich referee report i had for
this that i sent back um another another
thing that i did once or twice
was was write two referee reports one
was the one that i submitted anonymously
as if it had come into me as the editor
and then i which and then i would say
then i would write another letter saying
you know i think the referee was a bit
too blunt in his remarks and uh
and um
uh
uh you know should have toned down a
little bit here and apologize for this
and all this but but basically these
things had to be said and uh
uh
so um uh so sometimes i ghost wrote a
referee report and then um and then uh
changed it a little bit in the letter to
try to make make the thing uh
as far legacy it was the best way to to
get the uh
the proper uh
encouragement of the uh
i mean the proper uh training for the
for the for the person and still not
make him feel too bad but but let him
know
the facts
but
i i always try to to uh to have the
right the right outcome and it's not
just and justify the means i think it
was a way of a way of doing something
with
with uh uh
well
uh now this particular
so so here's a paper then i have many
referee reports on and um
and then and it turned out that i liked
uh uh
a surprising number of the referee
reports that i got that i got back in
but i but here i i the the the notation
was was
was horrible and not explained and there
were
there were uh there were there were
errors of fact and so on so there's
there's you know
a bunch of a bunch of uh numbered
comments made okay so then i got back
uh one of this report says i believe the
article deserves publication after
revision by the author and re-review so
that's uh basically the same judgment
that i had that that i had that is uh
it's got to have so much revision that
uh that then
then has another ref report has to be
made again here
and um and so commenting again on on
numerous points about uh
uh that weren't clear and and advice on
how to improve it and make it clear and
and how to how how to do it so that was
that was a uh
you know 10 points made on the paper
figure
here's another another
review that came by said a paper on the
subject indicated by the given title
should include one a complete precise
concise algorithm describing the method
of analysis two a proof or at least a
convincing explanation three a statement
describing the limitations inherent now
this paper had none of these in any way
it doesn't satisfy any of these so i
don't recommend its publication um
so he doesn't even encourage uh a
rewrite of the paper particular oh yeah
here he says
so uh i would encourage the author to
rewrite the paper with the guidelines in
mind and so let's
try again
um
i think this was class where it's very
nicholas
uh
reviewed then here's another one which
said there may be a little that is new
here but it's embedded in a network of
rediscoveries there's a large body of
published material and supplies
bibliography
many papers to read
in this if i recommend the author study
the following bibliography and roughly
the order given and then
and so a list of a list of seven papers
essentially saying that this man is such
a novice in the field he doesn't know
enough to write uh yet and he should
read these things and then
come back
uh so uh
carefully worked out bibliography um
but that person's judgment was that the
method was
was really not not worthy of publication
uh until it had been sorted out here's
another one
i find this paper very interesting
certainly worth publishing
um
in particular it appears to offer
significant advantages over other
published algorithms now this is
interesting because this particular
reviewer
was the one that i had referred to in my
in my uh
report to the author and said that i
thought that uh
um
that it was almost equivalent to the to
the algorithm described by the
in the paper so i had i had
um
i had heard in that regard uh but
because the actual author of the ned
irons who who i thought had
had already discovered most of the stuff
was was rather impressed by this ned is
a guy who who also likes it doesn't
doesn't know that
uh
different
nothing phases him he everything is
quick
it's something that looks very cryptic
to to me it always looks like like an
open book to him
did you know ned was he yeah okay so
yes okay what
oh yeah so um
uh so he uh so he uh actually sees this
as a
and uh
uh well he's been working with um
and now i realize he's been working with
seymour craig's machines which are sort
of
designed for this algorithm anyway uh
when he writes this but anyway this was
uh so he he uh uh has has suggestions so
he says
is not i feel the presentation is not as
clear as it should be and i've indicated
an additional copy where change might be
made and so he so he uh uh uh
he marked up the paper this this this
you do if there's if it was the most
convenient way to uh to communicate with
the author you just take the manuscript
and say you know i know you're going to
rewrite this anyway so i i actually
wrote on on it my remarks
and uh that's uh sometimes you do that
sometimes you don't depending on how
many changes there are but so he so then
he had also specific remarks that would
that would improve so i considered this
was a good
a good review also um
here's one
what
yeah yeah it's coming along but but i
started out with some people who i
thought would do reasonably good i was
mostly you know here i got back february
one not too not too bad
uh it's incredibly poorly written
um
now you know the transformation can now
rather loosely be written such and such
and
you know the author is even apologizing
for saying that he's not going to try to
explain something except make it loose
and all this
uh
and
so anyway you you uh
um
and there's some technical
uh problems here uh there was another
nice one this was peter wagner's review
i think it should be this paper should
be regarded as expository rather than a
research paper since it's concerned
almost exclusively with description
application of somebody else's algorithm
which deserves to be work more widely
known publication demanded provided
recommended provided the author prefer
to rewrite it more rigorous fashion and
then he gets
many pages of general comments on how it
could be improved and in fact then he
goes
numbered points one to twenty
and uh so
a lot of uh
of
good
thought went into it went into that um
this one here is um
okay i don't know this one was um
um
this was this was a one that i didn't
like because it didn't really ask for
very much and uh it it it
it was uh not a um
it was literally if if one of these
suggestions had been followed then we
would have published a pretty lousy uh
paper that nobody would get much out of
so compared to the other referee reports
this one doesn't go very
very much in it and here's one says this
paper cannot be read it has to be solved
like a puzzle
comments principally involved there's
things here and um
and then a very useful
i mean here's what you sometimes have to
do and say suggest that the author
rewrite the paper have it reviewed
locally by someone unfamiliar with the
algorithm and then resubmit in other
words sometimes you have to say before
you go to the refereeing process make
sure that at least somebody somebody
else
in your environment
can can understand it
um
and um
all right
this paper is written so on clearly it
can't be read with appreciable
comprehension that that's the reader
must construct for himself a person is
not inconsistent with the few clues
supplied
and
yes and
and then
it does uh and then it has a relevant
reference to uh uh to martin algorithm
by martin k which was in fact
uh quite useful for there um
well that's this now but i did have
one that recommended publication
uh
i guess this was in the cover letter so
so this guy had again had only minor
minor suggestions
oh did i lose the oh no
that's okay so so he gives he gives
references to another paper by ingram
which is which is wrong so anyway this
was all
now the funny thing happened though i
got a year i
got this letter two years later
uh from the editor-in-chief it says i
refer to a paper by so-and-so
this paper was originally received
and turned over to me when i became this
this is uh is this 65 should be 64.
these states are all off by a year
aren't they
no yeah these states are all off by a
year
uh but anyway um
apparently this paper has been
circulated privately to a number of
people and i have some reports which
said it contains a lucid explanation of
bottom to top syntactic analysis i
wonder if you might be in a position to
give me the latest report
and your opinion as to whether you
believe we should rescue the paper from
oblivion and so on so
anyway
the algorithm became known although the
paper that the author never did did you
write it so at least by my sending it
out to all these referees
it got the algorithm which which in
other words this guy hadn't invented a
new algorithm he was he was trying to
write an
exposition quote unquote of of somebody
else's algorithm which which now at
least got exposed by the fact that
referees knew about it but but he never
did did
um
and and he did publish another this
particular author i believe were
published
one one paper on fortran and then but i
don't know what happened to him soon
um now i would like i would have been
happier to conclude the story by saying
that this author uh
went on to uh
to become one of the great you know
authors of computer science this has
happened in one case that there was a
that i i wrote a very long referee
report to i bet i won't tell the first
this person's name but
but uh i really ripped up a paper and uh
that that was that needed to be
that needed to be this and i and uh
to don and i wrote but i wrote a long
report and i
and i thought i'd never uh this guy
would never you know
say
hi don to me ever ever again and uh i
got back a letter from him two years
later he said you know this changed this
this changed my life and i decided to to
to concentrate on writing and and uh
danny
he's got books out now he became a
very well respected uh
professor at at uh
uh
well-known universities and so on and uh
and uh he he he said that this actually
was uh
because he he got this strong criticism
back that would but did have suggestions
as to how to make it better and so that
worked all right
now
um question
yeah okay after reviewing a paper for
technical content and if you do feel
it's very weak and perhaps not worthy of
publication or at least that's your
recommendation
um would you spend the time to actually
go through in terms of
corrections and grammar and spelling and
maybe perhaps presentation
not
not grammar and spelling not at that
level not if it's not if not if that's a
major i would i would comment on that as
i would make it a quick note but i
wouldn't i wouldn't make a list i i
would just i would just allude to the
fact that that uh
that once you've got these out of i'll
play then then really you ought to use
the unique spelling checker or whatever
but then conversely though if you do
feel that it is worthy in terms of
technical content then you would
certainly spend the time then i spend
yeah then i put more time into into into
getting that extra spit and polish
yeah making it making it even better
that's right i i i believe in uh
in uh
making the publication as well as as
good as possible there's no there's no
reason why it's that's a bad idea that i
can think of
okay now
um
i wanted to show you some of the referee
reports i received recently
uh just to make to make this uh to bring
up more issues and make this more clear
so here's the letter i got from leo this
may this year
um
we'll give us this is a
acm transactions on graphics i showed
you the galley proofs for this paper on
monday
and uh he said that
as you can see the reference reports are
mostly quite positive well he's very
it's nice for him to say this i had
three referee reports one was very
negative and the other two were positive
so mostly they were positive
and so he accepts the paper publication
number of religions are in order as
indicated by the referee comment and so
then here are the referee reports and i
got these um
uh now here he uses a for a form
letter which uh which some editors will
do and others like uh leslie and i
discussed this he
unless he thinks that these are boring
these forms but it's sort of a checklist
you know is the title appropriate
is the abstract satisfactory are the key
words well chosen
if you don't ask these questions the
referees will might not think about
about these things and so
but it's pretty boring to say yes he's
section three yes c section three yes
he's section three section three is
comments yes
and um
and so um
uh so it's
kind of boring affiliates out but
uh but it goes through the the uh issues
that a referee ought to keep in mind so
do you would you put it in the research
section or there's another or another or
the practicing experience section okay
is it technically sound does it make
adequate reference to earlier
contributions no okay
and of course this is why i submitted to
acm transactions on graphics i i this is
a paper in which subject which i'd never
written before and i knew that they had
the referees who would know
uh
the
the
uh
what the
what the value of this work was it
seemed interested me but i didn't know
if it was rediscovery uh presentation
isn't well organized does it have excess
material does it lack material yes
reference to earlier work is it clear
yes satisfactory are more fewer figures
necessary it's okay
uh recommendation then you have a
different um
uh accept as is
with minor revisions reconsider after
major changes
um
and or reject and then there's another
one called submit to now this is
unfortunately after you check reject the
author will submit to something else
anyway i mean if there's enough journals
around that somebody will finally
finally filter down to the one that
that that has the standards of the paper
that's a that's a shame i guess that's
not always true but uh
uh
this
effect of life that you have to realize
that some
some
journals uh will
are more like uh
what does dijkstra call them right-only
journals
so
um
okay well
now
uh we're running short of time so i'm
going but i want to want to mention that
um uh it it the these comments here were
uh it was
uh both kinds every once in a while they
um
they made me feel good by saying that
that they actually enjoyed part of it
and you know it was nice to mix that in
with the criticism it's always good to
have something nice to say even though
your
basic messages uh you ought to work a
lot harder uh
you know it's just like it's just like
guiding a student
um
and um
so
it's uh uh
i mean
this not extremely original i've seen
very similar attempts both published and
unpublished i think it should be
published in order to save others from
reinventing the concept i mean that's
not exactly what i wanted to hear you
know okay
and so there's so then excellent
references are given um
and um
and so uh you know and and uh
unfortunately the references were
excellent except in one respect they
didn't give uh
the clues on i mean i you know s-p-i-e i
didn't know what that was and then i
found it finally through
through a bunch of hard work and they
never had page numbers on these things
uh on these references so it wasn't uh
possible to use here's a reference to a
phd thesis or a master thesis who knows
which
or how to get a hold of it
but
that was the first report the next one
it should be published before
publications and minor errors need to be
corrected some additional changes are
recommended and so on um
um and then it comments on technical
things actually i had a technical error
that uh that really uh you know i uh
this
referee caught and i thought it was
correct and
and uh i
went to program it on a computer even to
check and finally and and uh it took me
a half an hour an hour to figure out
that what that in fact i was wrong there
was something subtle going on there
needed to be explained but i thought i
had something obvious and and that was
was absolutely wrong
and then more references here completely
disjoint by the way from the references
supplied by the previous referee
uh and um so anyway so like so i uh and
then i had the third record report which
says um
uh
i took the examples hung them on a wall
had several people comment on them from
a distance of 15 feet it was recommended
uniformly all all preferred the
uh the uh
you know
my method the last and all this and um
um
i find very little to recommend the
technique and practice and uh that might
be something with theoretical interest
but but not for paper and all this so
this is uh this puts it in very good
pursuit so i was now this is again a
comment from a
from a uh
a
reader who was motivated so there will
be people so i know that if i had
published the paper as it was there
there would be a lot of people had this
same reaction very important for me to
have this kind of feedback
but especially it was important to have
those references uh in in the other ones
and i got copies of the references i
looked through the references and that
led me to another idea and in other
words i i had there were new ideas in
those references that could be combined
with the idea that i had and lead to a
brand new method that made the brought
the whole thing in sharper
sharper focus for me and and it was uh
then possible to come up with something
that i think is a real contribution
literature because uh now i knew from
this referee report what the what the
state of the art was i could write a
paper that would be consistent with
being famous
uh that you know people you know like
herb said some some people you're going
to they you know if there's a paper in
this acm transactions on graphics by
canoes well you expect that there's a
certain level of quality in there and
now i've got to live up to this uh and
uh and uh now i felt that i could
because of these referee reports and
because of the of the uh uh because of
the vice so i knew that leo had chosen
the people who would who would really be
reflective of the of the audience in
this uh and this was a um
a big help to me what
uh yeah yeah they knew and so at the end
of the at the end of the uh
paper then i has an acknowledgement now
the referees were extremely helpful
pointing me to literature which is aware
this led to substantial improvement the
methods in the exposition in this paper
which is absolutely true and
and um
so
that's uh uh
an example of refereeing at its best if
yeah it seems to me and it's recent from
my experience so i really appreciated
all three of the referee reports they
were quite honest and
and and helpful
okay